[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
my
[Music]
so
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
my
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
me
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
hey everybody how's it going can y'all
hear me
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
should be good
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
this
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
all right we're live what's going on you
guys gaming addict here let me shut my
door before people try to be rude gaming
out here coming at you for another attic
show we are back i'm here with my
co-host hustle and motivate how you
doing hustle
good um
a little odd that i'm i'm the co-host of
something but it feels good man um i am
extremely like humble and excited for
this new venture man we teaming up we
got other things in the works i'm happy
i feel good i'm actually sitting up
straight and all that though like i said
i know i'm excited to be here because
boy i wake up 3 30 in the morning and
boy am i tired but i'm definitely glad
to be here um i can't wait until we get
into the show man just but you know i
want to say before we get started thank
you you know
chose your boy you could have chose
anybody else right i know a few more
people who are more qualified but you
you're rocking with me you got me
incorporated with the fold with the with
the boys over here at lp man boys and
girls
and i'm excited for the future man like
this is uh
this is an opportunity that i wasn't
expecting but i'm definitely glad that
that you chose me i'm just saying i'm
just gonna keep it real
you know
there's a lot of things that people
don't realize when it comes to these
gaming stuff
is like you know first you need
availability you need someone that's
that that that's that's hungry that they
want to do it
because after even after after even a
couple years of doing iop sometimes i
wake up on iop
i'm like man
i was like but you know you you gotta
you gotta just pull through it and you
know here recently man the gaming has
been picking up what i like the most
about the year is the end of the year
because that's when all the good games
coming out i played death loot for two
hours this morning itching to get back
into that that's what i like the most is
when we play games and at the end of the
day man you've always showed the passion
and i've said on multiple times on
multiple occasions for multiple
different scenarios
i like seeing passion for this industry
more than i like seeing anything else
that's why i had to be human how to be
uh you know first thing we're going to
talk about today
hustle
is i feel like you know let's talk about
death loop
and in general because uh you know i
don't know if you've gotten any chance
to play it just came out so i don't
definitely uh
no that's probably not the case but you
know uh i actually got i played it for
two hours and you know i have to say
first off let let's talk about the game
in general i you said you did have some
questions for me when it came to death
loop uh you know let's get that out of
the way
i did i did um
me um what you'll soon realize about me
is i'm a music buff so
how's the soundtrack how's the ambiance
how's the atmosphere is there anything
that kind of stands out because i saw
you streaming it earlier but i couldn't
charge my phone so i i was watching it
on mute and i was back and forth but i
couldn't really get into the stream and
i didn't have a chance to watch it so
how's that ambiance
it's good like i can honestly say that
in terms of music there's a lot of
different sounds that goes into it now
um you know there are i do have some
nitpicks about the game but i will say
that the music on this game is on point
and arcane's usually pretty good at
music i remember you know especially uh
dishonored the original one like i don't
know if you played that but there was
like an ending song when you beat the
game
that i was like to this day i'd be
pumping at that man and like you know i
i like you know just the sound of you
know previous games like dishonored when
you when you first do the blink and you
hear that like that weird like chaotic
sound going on and you know
what i really appreciate this is
there there are a lot of scenarios in
death loop that doesn't have attention
to detail but there's a lot of scenarios
that do
uh you know obviously the perfect game
is the attention to detail and
everything but you know most games don't
have that but what i really enjoy about
it is music is definitely one of the
things they have intention to detail
okay all right so my next question and
uh sadly i haven't had a chance to play
this just yet um
how are the controls because it's a
first person title and it doesn't make
me motion sick or anything but like a
lot of first-person games like i i would
have to play that now on a wide screen
so i got to get my wide screen back in
here but how are the controls
and are you able to see everything are
you playing away are you playing this on
pc or the x ps5
ps4 oh ps4 that's right that's right
it's a time exclusive right
up shame on me shame on me for not
knowing
how okay it's on console and
okay how's the field of view on console
uh the field of view is pretty good
actually um i didn't really have too
much of an issue
i think that like the biggest
some of the textures like for instance
like the water
it's a little iffy but
you know like especially going through
the game
and you know the sun going throughout
the mountains like it's a really nice
looking game obviously it's not perfect
you know that there are certain aspects
of the game that you is just like what
is this but it and not one time was i
played this game i felt like it had like
last gen graphics or anything like that
you know what i'm saying
it's kind of like final fantasy vii the
majority of the game looks amazing but
there are certain games that use like yo
who made this sleigh
okay so i have a question about the game
because i'm a little unfamiliar is this
game like a roguelite or rogue like not
sure how to pronounce that term but
is that how this game is like once you
die do you start all the way over um
so pretty much how it goes is when when
you start the game
that you kind of like actually you know
spoiler it's not really spoiler i'm only
talking about like the first three or
four minutes like 10 minutes of the game
like you you're acknowledging that
you're in this cycle you know because
obviously it it
it kind of is a roguelike but it's not a
roguelike
it's kind of weird because i feel like a
roguelike is some form of random nation
you know what i'm saying like hades when
you come into a god you know the gods
are random what god you're going to get
what the abilities that the gods have
are random return everything is random
but on this for the most part from what
i've played everything is identical
where it is
so like you know if you know where that
you picked up that uh there's like a
nail gun to for stealth that gun to my
knowledge right now because i only have
two hours into it it's going to be there
every time that you go get it you know
what i'm saying
so kind of like the spawning and uh
demon souls um
i tried playing that game i ain't no
good at it but i did try playing that
game and after a while it's kind of like
the mega man syndrome the way you know
where everything is the second you get
through the layout of whatever level
that you're on okay all right that's
good to know that's good to know that
might actually be a little bit easier
for me because boy i tried playing
return
uh
nope i don't want no smoke man you saw
it you saw them streams i still didn't
beat it i dropped it like i got nothing
against maternal it's a good game
in my opinion it's a good game you could
tell the qualities there you could tell
the
what i like that they did is a lot of
people don't like the negative uh like
the negative buffs do you get return but
i feel like that's the only thing they
did to evolve that friend uh like the
roguelike experience like you know maybe
redefine that a little bit but for the
most part it is nice that's like yo you
can pick this up it's gonna give you a
negative buff but if you do certain
requirements you'll get rid of that
negative buff and you'll just keep the
buff
so i do feel like they did that good
that's good
but
when i do die on return on it's not like
when i die in hades when i die in hades
i'm like yo
i got this i just gotta re-go do this
again when i die on maternal i'm like
i'm uninstalling this [ __ ] like
i'm done like and i feel like they need
to to change that i feel like there's
not enough
uh what's what i'm looking for there's
not enough things where i feel like
the game
is rewarding you when you do die
and i think they need to change that
aspect of it uh i understand completely
all right all right okay so
there
are wow okay there are
certain aspects
from an arcane game that i really
haven't experienced like that so for a
first timer like myself
do you think that i would be able to get
into this game and the reason why i
asked that is because this game seems to
be critically acclaimed i saw the nines
and the tens and i saw a surprise in him
from gamespot and we know that they
don't hand them joints out they do not
hand them out like no brown turkeys
i did notice that they gave it a 10.
yeah that yeah and we know how they go
um tamir
assan i think is the gentleman's name
but
i know that you know i know this this is
a thing
i want to know just from from your
perspective and you know i'm a i'm a
pretty bad gamer however i can get
through most things do you think that i
would enjoy this game if i picked it up
for the first time
i think that it still feels like an
arcade game arcane game um there is a
lot of feeling that you get when playing
like dishonored and stuff
you know it was so bad that when i
crouch because and dishonored when you
crouch like you rotate your knife from
like like you're stabbing to someone to
like like you're slitting someone's
throat so like i always like that
attention to detail because if if you're
crouching
no you probably would have the dagger
that way you know what i'm saying you
didn't do that in here i know that
shouldn't make that shouldn't make me
feel away but it does it makes me feel
away i'm sitting here looking like man
why did you just rotate that dagger just
a little bit but that's not a big deal
like i don't think so far i've played it
i don't think that
there's a difficulty spike like like for
instance like they gave me this like
this this rifle
and this this damn thing's busted
like you can literally see me on the
stream one-shotting everyone with this
damn rifle
like and i was getting a full-blown
combat with like 10-15 people
okay when you die
you don't really die like you you kind
of like reverse time you can do that
twice before you die die and you have to
start the whole day very good
okay
like i died the first time i'm okay i'm
not going on that ridge it's over not
going up there so i stayed at the the
doorway and i just kept like pumping my
head through pop one off and i just kept
doing that and then
one of the big things i could criticize
this game is like
the faces look crazy like not in a good
way like it's like come on man like you
killing these people over and over again
sometimes i see the same face and they
look they look be like like out like in
my nightmares faces like
wait wait you mean like the same type of
npcs like enemy npcs a lot of reused
assets in this game oh okay okay all
right all right well that yeah
yeah it's not the end of the world but
you know yeah it is criticism because
most of the time when you see these
people you're going to shoot them anyway
what's up big cloud but you know what up
what i just enjoy
the concept of the game obviously in the
trailers the whole point of the game
we're not bringing that up i told the
chat not to bring that up
she said what happened addict died by
falling off a cliff
don't act like it happened
i'm gonna need i need a timestamp for
that
buddy is like
like yeah i actually bring it up in the
stream what was funny is i mean i don't
think we're going to uh we're going to
copyright my own self that would be
weird if i copyright myself but the the
funny thing was when i what i was
playing it like there's this part where
you have to kill a bunch of people right
i'm not going to really go too much into
that and i'm looking down on this ridge
and i'm like okay you know
yeah
i already see it so i'm looking down and
i'm like okay i got this so i'm looking
down this ridge and i'm thinking that
there's like a ramp right below me so
let me go ahead and uh bring this on the
stream because i'm sure people are
wanting to they they everyone wants to
laugh at me uh together and that's okay
we can laugh at me together
so that this is what happened you guys
like yo you
so i was going up here now if you notice
here
there's a chick up here i'll wait a
couple seconds so it'll be on the stream
uh hustle so you you'll see this trick
right here so i'm assuming this part
here has a ramp
you know what i'm saying
actually they might not be able to see
it because of i haven't seen anything
yet yeah hold up let me let me go ahead
debt this real quick guys
um let me just put a display real quick
because you guys got to see this real
quick like it it i felt there now you
guys should be able to see it so now
this is pretty much how how it went
now i obviously go up these stairs like
when you get here there's this point
right here and there's this person here
so i'm thinking there's a ramp right
here you know what i'm saying there's a
ramp right here so i'm not looking i'm
assuming there's a ramp i'm about to go
on to and then i'll fall completely down
and die
and then i was sitting there i was like
we're not mentioning that like we're not
gonna mention that that never happened
like because it it it looked really bad
it looked really bad on my end
i was sitting there i died and the
moment i fell off that balcony i'm like
i did not just do that
like i did not just do that and what's
funny is if it would have been like
dishonored and mid drop i would have
blinked up there again but there's
there's no blink i'm i'm so used to
having blinking arcade game where i fell
it was just over it was dead it was over
i was sitting here and the first thing i
said when that happened that didn't
happen we ain't talking about that i
want no one bringing this up on iop
sunday
shout out to the two dollar super chat
from gerald mack all held to iop salute
addicts
addicts world
we definitely need to get an emote made
eventually for that but you know that
that was the funny part you know for the
most part you guys
i gotta hand it to the to arcane this is
a good game
i've enjoyed it now if you see
the if you see the the commercials for
this you you have to assassinate people
and what i like
dishonored was about assassinating
people
so what i like is they took the same
concept the same gameplay they evolved
it and they really
pretty much made the same game it's just
with a twist now you're in a loop day
over and over again
oh yeah i don't know how that happened
well i will fix that right now guys
don't worry about it okay
but um
so you know we're sitting there
and
you you open it up you know and then you
you know you pretty much have to kill
eight people in one day
so you have to okay you have to
kind of
scout everything out you have to find
out where everyone is and then you have
to do things so fast because there's not
a lot of time and you have to kill all
the people in the game all the main
people in the game and so like that's
the concept and that's not really
spoiler that was literally in the
trailers to see i was mistaken and they
mentioned um
the main antagonist in the trailer she's
the black woman and then it just wasn't
a child from the trailer
she is amazing
okay yeah
every time you have to make me go back i
look every time i see
this this person
i immediately like oh yeah like and
what's funny is like you're
acknowledging
can you please fix the camera we cannot
i fixed it you just have to wait a
couple of seconds
like
what i love is you acknowledge that
you're in a loop you know what i'm
saying
and she acknowledges she's in a loop
so you guys are constantly talking [ __ ]
to each other
she's good man she's a really good
character and the main character he's
good too i like him like they did a
really good job on this man and you know
that's what we're going to get into the
first topic we're going to talk about
i know
we need to see what these
studios make for microsoft but to me
we see psychonauts we see the outer
worlds we see
uh you know right now we're seeing um we
say waistline three that was like 80
something metacritic
we're seeing um what's that other studio
that uh we see arcane with the uh death
loop
like i don't know is it me
am i being crazy hustler do i feel like
you can justify the purchases already
with just the quality of games that
they've made sure they haven't been an
exclusive sure some of them might be
exclusive to playstation but that to me
that doesn't take away from the fact of
the studios
that they purchased in the type of games
that they can make
well yeah it's good job for microsoft
even though with def loop is going
through what it's going through now
good job because this these are the the
seeds
that are being planted that we can see
we're going to see all of this growing
to a tree if this if this is like the
first lineup um i haven't played the
ascent but from what i understand it was
kind of like a lukewarm reception but
however however if if all of this is
like early work and then pretty much
once everything becomes exclusive uh
i'll use the nba term i know you're not
necessarily in the sports but the second
they had mid season form or playoff form
in terms of microsoft and the different
studios that they have
there's a lot to
have for uh game pass uh one of the
that xbox live reaction that e3 reaction
when i was with you guys
i said you know starting in july like it
really gives you microsoft really gave
you a reason to own game pays from the
ascent
from psychonauts to which i haven't
played yet you know well i know this
game isn't on game pass but they've
really given you a actual reason to like
invest in the service and yeah if this
game really takes off like i see i will
definitely see some playstation people
coming on over to xbox the hardcore ones
coming on over if this game hits the way
that you just explain something because
it sounds like it's like a lot of fun
yeah definitely imagine if we get a
sequel and it's on oh you will only
we're going to see death loop on xbox
only when the original one was only on
playstation and then you're going
obviously it's going to come to xbox
next year but then you're gonna see
sunset overdrive two hitting playstation
when it was only an xbox game i think
it's crazy how things have turned around
like it's ironic
it's like you know people are talking
about star field like let's talk about
the bethesda games like you know i get
it people say bethesda's past their
prime uh
wolfenstein says hi wolfenstein writered
well done well everyone loved it doom
maternal was considered probably to a
lot of people
the game of the year last year
uh you know and i get it like their
their key studio
they're making star field but it's like
at the same time to me hustle we can't
judge them off of making starfield until
we see more
on star field like and i get it it goes
the other way around we got to see more
in terms of what they're making
i i'll say the in terms of like the
starfield thing
you know that is what it is and it's
going to be what it's going to be i feel
like it's going to be um elder scrolls
2.0
but just in space all fall out in space
and now i don't i really don't want to
get an analogy but what we'll definitely
have to see what that is
i think um the hopes are really hard for
that one and for a good reason according
to that little trailer that we saw it
looked cool man and i can't wait to see
more i know um i think it was either
yourself it was a game before i can't
remember who it was yeah i said oh man
what you would have saw gameplay now the
rollout is the what the rollout is it's
a little cgi trailer we know the joint
dropping next year so around e3 and we
know how it does to do it at eight three
time anyway not to get off course but we
know how they do all right we announced
something that may not join soon to drop
same thing they did with dual material
same thing they would do with doom 2016
and those games were definitely well
received by a lot of those pc guys man
if there wasn't xbox guys they're gonna
have to get down and lay down man i know
i know you can get it on pc but you can
play it for as low as 15 a month on game
pad so that's this is going to be
extremely dope and there are certain
games and i know where i mention them
later but there are certain games that
i'm looking forward to like like a back
for blood which comes out next month
that like that's reason enough for me to
get game plays even if i only play at
about 10 hours like that's that's reason
enough for me to get it microsoft is
really having like
they on the run i know that this game is
on playstation and we got to reiterate
that but microsoft is definitely on a
little they're on the long run right now
i hope it don't nothing
look if they can finish off the year
right with halo which i'm keeping my
fingers crossed but if they can finish
off the year right man
the future's bright the future's already
bright but it's just going to be even
better the second you know that that
the end of the year
icing on the cake man work out with halo
man i hope it worked out so we got to be
a little bit spicy on here uh
all right hustle we got to this is just
it's just the attic show man we got to
be a little bit spicy there's a huge
thing going on right now on twitter
obviously you know we got we got to get
a little bit into the console thing just
a little hair uh people want to know
in terms of a fanboy who deserves to who
deserves the bragging rights when it
comes to death loop is it the highly
rated
console that it's on playstation or is
it
xbox studio made the highly rated game
that it went on xbox who and your
personal opinion who would you think
would deserve those bragging rights
i would have to i'm saddened with the
with same blue even though team green
made it i'm sad i'm siding with team
blue and here's why they have access to
this game and nobody else does i don't
know why initially i thought it was on
pc i didn't know it was it was uh no no
it's on the light system it's just it's
just not on xbox
oh oh okay okay all right okay do i want
to recap my statement okay in the fan in
the fanboy wars
team blue got that that is something
that they can kind of hold like over
over y'all i don't party you know i
don't participate none of that bs though
however however if if i am a playstation
fan
i think i think it's extremely dope that
they can kind of go back and forth
because you remember a little bit last
year or earlier this year um it might be
the show
a playstation made game is on xbox and
it's like the highest selling mlb game
so like this this is just you know
granted it's all in fun but i'm rolling
the playstation man i'm rolling with
playstation i'm glad i got ps5 if i ever
want to try it out if i didn't have a pc
and i had a ps5 it's the only way i
could play it man and that's that to me
is hilarious by the way i don't know how
that how did it happen but
it did and here we are but playstation
manager
because at the end of the day i do feel
like
look
i will give some props to xbox that you
know this shows this this does look like
optically it looks good on xbox because
it shows the type of quality studio that
they can make
but at the end of the day
do like do you think this game's gonna
be relevant in a year hustle let's be a
hundred
okay i don't know it's going to
i'll i'll say this i'll say this right
we i i'm a fan of game pace regardless
of how people may feel about i'm a fan
of game pass
if well not that i would choose the way
to play games anyway but here's what i
will say if the story is hidden because
when you were talking about the other uh
your antagonist
if they're interacting like that and the
story is hitting for something good then
yes it's definitely going to be relevant
i feel like games with a good story as
you know i guess we'll talk about this
one later and i guess we'll talk about
this one later uncharted football
yeah i did i did i guess we'll talk
about that later games with good stories
they never really go out of style
but that's just my opinion on it i don't
think it'll ever go out of style if this
story is that good i know you said
you're two hours and i have not played
it yet but if the story is that good
you know then you know it's gonna go
down it's gonna go down in history
so it'll definitely be relevant a year
from now
i i see i think the biggest thing that i
can give them
when it comes down to it is
look like i do think that game pass will
be a relevant conversation because
people aren't going to have to be buying
this it's going to be in the service uh
but you know what would be crazy hustle
is that they because obviously they they
did an out of worlds 2 already and that
game's probably not going to be until
like 2023 maybe the beginning of 2024.
but what happens if they come out of e3
next year
and they're like they announce a trailer
for death loop two
only on xbox like well you get what i'm
saying pc too
yeah and i get what you're saying um my
first question is how are you um
how big is arcane studios i know i i
defer that to you because i got a
feeling that y'all wouldn't know see
that's something that i wouldn't know
um if we know anything about the gaming
industry is that you know but that's
that has multiple studios and they can
it wouldn't surprise me if this game is
doing well they're already cracking on
some dlc or they're already cracking on
you know i mean or part two so it
wouldn't surprise me man like if that's
that's something else according to
google there's 150 people at uh arcane
this was updated in 2020 so they could
you know this is probably before the
the acquisition so maybe microsoft's let
them improve their library a little bit
more uh so i would say that you know
maybe 10 15 more 20 30 people more
that's it if it could be less i don't
know but i feel like
to because uh red fall we're about to
talk about that obviously that's ironic
we're talking about death loop and the
next topic is is red fall and they're
made by the same studio but you know um
i think it's good man i think death loop
is definitely
a viable option to play i do think it's
a reason to to play on playstation i
don't think so far it's it's a console
seller you know i think it's just one of
those things where if you have an xbox a
playstation you you should pick this up
but it's not one of those things where
you should go pick up a playstation to
buy
okay
so i like that
let's
have you seen these red fall screenshots
[Laughter]
you're smiling so i assume you have i i
saw i saw a few i saw a few on my lunch
break today
yeah boy that man looked like cyberpunk
boy that thing was looking crazy
i don't know i don't know man it listen
listen i'm not going to be too harsh
before we get into it um well
we have to lead the people and let the
informed people of what we're speaking
of let me
i don't think
let me just find the screenshots go
ahead and uh go and set it up real quick
i'll find the screenshots
okay so a little bit over the weekend
ladies and gentlemen
somebody
on
reddit i do believe went ahead and
leaked the screenshots for the early
alpha of red fall now if we know it
before we get started if we know
anything about ndas or if we know
anything about being picked for wanting
to play one of these games they will
make you sign the nda like you probably
couldn't stream it you definitely would
you definitely couldn't stream it you
definitely couldn't like record your own
footage more than likely um it's not
supposed to hit the public under any
circumstances
um i think this was found in reset era i
said ready it might be it may have been
found a reset era however
somebody was bold enough
somebody was bold enough to leak a lot
of screenshots to leak a lot of weapons
there's even some story based stuff in
there that i wrote down but i don't want
to reveal it but i think this may have
been in the trailer but they even say
what the game takes place
um it's a travesty and this is from
somebody who wants some of those
opportunities to be an early beta tester
to do these types of things the way you
see people abuse like their privilege
and abuse their power man
like if you really think about it like
because that's hurting that's hurting us
as content creators because now
they're gonna be more you know picky on
who they give these kind of stuff to
it's just like look like i get it you
want that two minutes of clout and i
don't even know why you would want that
but it's just like just just grow up you
know what i'm saying
here is the the screenshot i'm gonna i'm
gonna put it okay in the middle of us a
little bit
so that ain't looking crazy boy yeah so
here's the screenshot it's gonna cover
us just a little bit i'm going to get
rid of it momentarily into the topic but
you know there's this screenshot now
what i do want to bring up because i'm
looking at it now is
from what we saw at e3 first off it was
a cgi and that that's one of the issues
i'm completely against cgi cutscenes
because to me
you didn't really like you didn't really
set expectations for anything
but
this
this isn't it you know what i'm saying
like
and keep in mind like i do want to point
out keep in mind
this is an alpha this was never supposed
to go out to the public
ever
uh and i do i think it's gonna look like
this when it comes out no not even
remotely that people were showing
screenshots of destiny and
literally it looked worse than this
but
when the game came out it looked way
better than what was shown on those
screenshots
a lot of things can be done in the
amount of time from right now to release
keep in mind we don't have a release
date either
we're just going off the information we
have now these are the screenshots being
shown
it does make it look a little spooky it
does
but at the same time
you know we do got to keep in mind this
isn't the retail game uh that's why i'm
so against cgi to this degree because
all that cgi cutscene did is just kind
of show what the game's going to be
about and to me didn't even show what
the game is going to be about uh but we
do got to keep in mind that you know we
have to
uh i just wanted that information out
there you guys could take it upon
yourself me personally i don't know
about you hustle we'll get to you in one
second but
i'm not going to hold this screenshot in
the ultimate thing this is how the game
is going to look when the game launches
i'ma hold this screenshot is look it's
an alpha thing
someone jumped the gun when they weren't
supposed to i'm not expecting the game
to look like this at launch
okay so
nine foot i believe his name is nine
foot ut in the chat he actually took my
ass i was gonna bring up the fact that
when god of war when
i think true how you shoot it went to go
see god of war for the first time
it i could say it looked like that but
it looked pretty bad in in pretty bad
state so like you know just because you
you might see a game that's playable
it'll just look like complete trash but
it doesn't mean that that's the end and
yes this is an alpha and this is the
reason why i said alpha as opposed to
beta beta is something that's really
pretty much ready for consumer release
at a certain point certain changes
may be made to a beta that may not be
made what have you we know where the
alpha changes are gonna be made um this
doesn't really deter me for this game
just like seeing that like oh i call
this an alpha it shouldn't have been
leaked in the first place and that's one
of the reasons why i shouldn't have been
leaked but that doesn't like deter me
also addict i think this game comes out
next year in
the middle of may or not the middle east
i think this comes out like mid next
year and i thought i saw that on
eurogamer and that's kind of what i
thought i saw that when i was doing
research for this project release dates
i don't think it's got a release date
yet it's just 2020. well it says 2022. i
thought it said mid but okay if i'm
wrong on that
my bad y'all my fault but um i
definitely saw that but like yo but
people are running around and
like you know because people they do the
console war thing hey look i'm that word
i'll be honest with you i think the next
time they show set game
it's yeah i mean
look the next time they show the game
and if it's in that state again all
right you know i might get to sweating a
little bit but
yeah you know i mean there's some people
in the chat saying you know that this
isn't official it's not but we are
content creators we're in a podcast
formation this is what's being talked
about so we're gonna talk about it you
know at the end i'm not gonna act like
it doesn't exist
like
like you know and there is this you know
disclaimer thing that you know uh
microsoft don't have to invest a whole
lot of money into projects because of
stuff like game pass so this is a
narrative that people will go with so we
do got to talk about it
did you know i'm addict to get back to
some of that console stuff on twitter i
want to say i saw somebody compare that
to like god of war something like that i
saw a crazy comparison when it came to
rainfall and then someone on playstation
i was like come on y'all like yo this is
wait let's just wait but you know and i
think um i think it's it's cool that we
are talking about it a for the people in
in the audience who may not be
savvy enough to even
know about certain things they may not
know about the god of war thing um like
uh nine foot in the chat um it may not
be common knowledge to a lot of people a
lot of people may not go back and watch
certain documentaries or even how
things are made so now this this is
extremely important that we do talk
about it because the influence that you
and i both have i think it's cool that
we we push out like the the right
message yeah at least we do our best to
push out the right man
we're talking about it because you know
we're not going to come out here and say
you know other outlets you know i'm not
designated i'm just saying like the
wrong message would be a this is what
the game is going to look like they
wouldn't give no content behind where
this came from they wouldn't get no
conscience behind it this is an alpha
beta they say this is what the game
looks like this is not what the game is
going to look like at launch but i do
feel like you know we're going to talk
about it and we're going to discuss
whether or not you know stuff like this
this should never have been leaked
yeah for sure um
part of me just as a creator
part of me
hopes
all right look you probably go home and
you got to get sued behind that i'm just
going to be real yeah
you you got to dog and just as a creator
like if i had something under wraps and
then somebody exposed it a little bit
and like it was like the rough thing oh
nah
man my team of lawyers stronger the
linebackers boy you got you gonna have
to hold that cuz
that's that's why
when it comes to nintendo no one messes
with nintendo
oh no
look look at that face you had when i
said nintendo
why why do you think i brought this and
i didn't i i i'm nervous that you even
showed that on the stream
oh yeah they might try to clap the
screen
hey hey my fault yo i'm joking i'm
joking with you oh man oh man but no
that's nintendo they're not for play
play but yeah um i kind of hope
i hope people
not the fan boys but i really hope the
people who saw this don't have like a
negative effect on the game i really
hope they give it a fair shake because i
got a feeling we're going to see it
again but at some point we'll see it
again but i just hope you know the gang
gets a fair shake and you just
sometimes we got to be patient we got to
give everybody time to get their self
together i think that you're going to be
all right man i'm just going to be real
with you
i think you're going to i think the
graphics are going to drastically
improve between now and release and the
biggest thing that i can really you know
voice my opinion on is like this is
going to be it looks like a looter
shooter in a way like i don't know
exactly how it's going to be
i'm more upset that it's not dishonored
3 and i'm gonna keep saying this until
it is dishonored three but at the same
time like
i can't keep screaming that microsoft
needs to be more appealing more diverse
but then when i keep asking to make the
same game over and over again so you
know there's room for yeah there is room
for for death uh death luke 2
um death luke 2
red fall and dishonored 3 and i feel
like my but behind microsoft's
leadership and the way that they're
doing this i think we can easily get all
those games uh because i do feel like
you know when it comes to how game pass
is structured
i feel like it
i feel like you know it kind of hurt
their marketing but it helped their
marketing at the same time because now
when they do marketing for game pass
they can oh let let's let's have a game
pass uh commercial but let's have it
heavily halo themed you know what i'm
saying
like that though start theming their
game pass commercials off of the biggest
games coming out that year and i feel
like that's a lot easier to
do in terms of marketing than it is just
to market fresh games every other couple
months
but you know so
you know what was he going to say
i was going to say if this we're going
gonna wrap up here before we move on um
i'm kind of worried about back for blood
i know we were talking about the whole
game pass thing i'm a little i'm just a
little i just i don't think it's gonna
be a bad game i just think it may
release at the wrong time because
doesn't
horizon five forza horizon five like
come out like the very next month
uh yes
yes it comes out in november that's
ooh
and and i know it had nothing to do with
nothing but i think we were something
like the luda shooters and all that the
whole full player co-op thing that's
what made me just think about that like
i'm
and that one looks cool to me too i'm
back for blood looks real cool for me
man like i remember like when they first
showed the trailer and everything and
they got i got my sister they got her
hair right and everything like that that
to me was dope that that hey that's that
super dope man i like all that but i'm
i'm more worried about that guy and i
know that that had nothing to do with
nothing i apologize for the tangent
ladies and gentlemen but it just it made
me think about like it really made me
think about the rollout and when i spoke
earlier about game pass and how they
really want to make you subscribe
i hope that that game has legs as well
so it's just a thing it's this thing i i
hope all these i hope all these games
really do well that's better than
bleeding edge dude that's for sure boy
i really like that too it hurt me when
that game went down i felt like
that game
well it's not going to brighten that up
oh my god oh this is cool
cause i tried playing that thing too
i liked the concept and i thought it was
executed okay
but there were certain things they
needed to do to make it more appealing
uh you know first thing it should have
been free to play
i don't know why it wasn't i it's just
it's a shame because i do feel like that
game had a lot of potential
as far as like the back for blood thing
i don't i think there's such different
games i don't think it's gonna matter
and i do think that since uh since back
for blood's on playstation that they're
gonna get a lot of their sales on that
platform anyway and i feel like because
of left 4 dead and the fans that that
franchise had i think the game is going
to be fine too but i do get it like you
know forza is a big franchise but at the
same time forza and you know left 4 dead
and back for blood are two different
genres as well do you think that you
know might help
help regenerate that a little bit
oh yeah i see and thank you for
educating me because i didn't know that
game was a multiplayer like i said when
they showed it on um when they showed it
during the microsoft conference i want
to say it said it was going to be in
game pace and that's what made me think
yeah that's that's that's why i assume
that i apologize for that that's why i
assume there was an exclusive so i'm
like oh okay well then i'm not worried
then all right well it will be something
like left for dead it will be something
like left for dead and it'll it'll have
his fan base and that'll grow over time
and that it is and i know that that's
kind of everywhere else then i'm cool
all right then i ain't worried then see
now i'm not worried i thought it was
just the xbox one thing yeah so all
right let's let's let's get to the
majority of the show because this is
probably going to be right
so we finally got to do the playstation
showcase we got to
participate in it uh you did the
reactions with us you know uh first off
before we go and break the showdown you
know give your general
feeling during the show hustle how did
you feel about the show
all right so i gave this show a seven
out of ten at first when i was with you
guys has that changed
yes it has it actually changed that live
stream
it changed that it changed no one went
up to 8 out of 10. listen listen the
show wasn't a bad show now i understand
that playstation has to
appease their third-party relationships
i understand that they have to do that
but
all they had to do and i think jack move
said this best they could have put
something big in the beginning right
they could have like spread it out they
could have put like the uncharted thing
on pc right i know a lot of people ain't
big on that i'm big on that because i
love uncharted but they could have did
it could have sectioned it off the way
all right they had the indie section but
here's the playstation thing they had
the third party stuff but here's the
playstation thing they could have lived
with the playstation thing outside of
that commercial that we saw when they
were playing chess they had 21 savage
playing chess i didn't know what was
going on king was dying hysterically
over there man but i didn't know what
was going on we we're all we're confused
we didn't know we me and cognito
we were confused but they could have
spaced that out they really could have
done that pacing a little bit and it's
granted this was not a bad show but it
was just
the top of it
it's like eating like it's like your
mother making you eat all your
vegetables first and it's like not even
like the good vegetables it's like
kidney beans or something like kidney
beans and liver that we didn't want that
first but um they really really made you
wait till it ends for all of the
yeah we didn't want that man it was like
before you could have your cherry
cheesecake and all that before you can
hand that you got to sit through this
um
oh what's that project eve and i guess
we'll get into a game by game i like
that i like i like the way we i think
everybody's kind of positive on that too
it wasn't just like us or from the
community
everything that i saw in the community
i'm not gonna lie i thought it i don't
think it was bad but you know when i saw
it i think it was mainly because i was
having computer issues because that's
before i hooked up the new computer but
i'm just sitting here looking at this
thing and i'm just like first off i had
like hardcore platinum games
like
nightmares i'm not a big platinum games
person so i'm sitting here looking at
this and i'm like
damn like like i don't want to play
another platinum games game but i don't
it looked okay
i saw some people in the industry
addressing how the the individual looked
uh yeah i saw that too to me
i get it you know she's definitely hyper
sexualized i get it but at the same time
i say this all the time
uh the people that are doing this the
most is the part of the world that don't
give two shits what anyone else has to
say about it like
you know but
over there in the east they they do it
they they don't mind doing it and it's
actually accepted over there for the
most part like and it's just like look
like you know people might disagree but
it's just like at the end of the day to
me hustle we cannot say
give the the
developers freedom to do what they want
but then the moment they do something we
don't want it we try to correct it like
no
it's got to be both ways you know i
actually didn't look at this chick and
automatically
had those kind of you know thoughts like
that didn't even remotely come into my
mind like a and to me if you're thinking
that first
i'm thinking like are you even a gamer
because you're not even looking at the
gameplay like that's being shown
okay
i didn't want to address that i didn't
really
even pay her no mind i was like okay
this
initially would have reminded me of it
was bayonetta and devil may cry what it
initially reminded me of and i know you
you said you had an issue with um
platinum i mean a lot of people got
issues with platinum but like that's
just the mind frame it put me in i was
more impressed by like the monster
detail by the enemy detail like yeah i
looked at oh oh girl or whatever but i'm
like yo it was
it was some type of
cross monster i don't know what in the
world that thing was and then i said
what is that like that that was one of
those moments and i'm like yo that's the
third party game you know we booting up
that 2080 ti for that one sir hey look
man steam got the hat at man but that's
that that was cool man that was oh that
was extremely dope that was extremely
dope um we have a super chat from uh
with the 20 super chat both of y'all
keep up the good work shout out to acg
man you know i've always said it
multiple times that dude is so real it's
not even funny man like you know when
you be being in these youtube streets as
long as i have i've came across my share
fair
of people that
appear something on twitter but in real
life they're not that person acg is that
way 24 7. like and i appreciate that man
i really appreciate the support but you
know as far as going on top of what we
were talking about you know the way that
people are generalizing stuff like i get
it does that make it right no because
you know in a way people do have a lot
of uh physically a lot of the stuff that
makes no sense on how some of these
women are made in these games but at the
same time
like
look like i guess don't buy the game
like
i don't
have a good way of
of combating that like to me it's like
we said earlier like you know if we want
to give creative control to some of
these developers
it got to be everywhere it can't be just
one section because it's it's appealing
to what you want to and i agree with you
a lot of the things that is done in the
in these gaming streets in terms of how
women are portrayed and doesn't make
sense in that type of gameplay like you
know they'll have like a little bit of
cloth like right here like that one
little thing and it's like that wouldn't
even that wouldn't even make that
doesn't even make sense like the angles
this woman is jumping that i that that
outfit something a real woman wouldn't
wear you know what i'm saying but it's
just like at the same time it's just
like you gotta let them be creative and
for you know what's funny is some of
these scenarios they've dug it and a
woman has made some of these these
outfits and stuff
yeah yeah
one thousand percent uh i'm gonna get
i'm gonna put well i'm not gonna really
push back on that i mean honestly if
and i know the gentleman that was
speaking off i mean you know he has his
right to his opinion i i may not even
agree because when we first saw project
i'm like oh she looked cool like that
was like my first thought it wasn't like
oh she looked thick and all that it was
not she looked cool like to me i didn't
even like kind of thought process and
maybe maybe because like you know we we
don't imag because i've never been the
kind of person to like sexualize like
animated characters so i think that
might be have to have something to do
with it because when i see like
an attractive looking person in a game
the first thing i don't think of is like
my mind don't go to the gutter or
anything like that like
it's never done that but i can
understand there's a lot of people that
do and i can understand like wanting to
fix that that area in general
well i'm gonna tell you this as a kid my
mind went to the gutter but that's only
because i was a kid no i don't know
better but
it's just one of them things like nah we
saw low you saw laura crawford well i
saw laura croft and i was i remember
when that was the whole thing but like
that was i think i was years ago like
just as an adult like
in the words of neo game spark i go
outside and i touch grass so like when i
first saw her it was like oh okay cool
and she just looked cool to me like the
character design look cool but all those
character designs look cool to me like i
said i brought up one of the enemies
toward the end of that trailer man
hey look i just hope listen this i'm
getting it on pc i hope it runs well and
um we have a five dollar super chat from
mr jarrod a minute
we gotta find out from gerald mack you
would think ps fans would be more
appreciative of xbox games for saving
face of their preferred platform but no
you know he got a point there man like
like playstation be feeding xbox be
feeding these playstation fanboys
recently they got psychonauts now they
get death loop you know definitely hurts
a little bit more because it's not on
xbox but i can't make the game be on
xbox but you know what i definitely want
to bring up is you know we want to back
pedal go back to that original topic
real quick
i just feel like personally when i saw
project evo i didn't even look at
anything like that the only thing eve
the only thing i was thinking is not
another damn
platinum game like that's all i was
thinking the entire time so you know
let's go ahead and start breaking these
games down yeah you know uh might be
so
i could
so let's go ahead and so we got god of
war here so the first game was thought
was
knights of the old republic
yes
how did you feel about knights of the
old republic
okay so you know the nostalgia that
everybody has for kotor that that was in
the early xbox live days
i never had that i never had that um i
didn't hop online until 2007. it wasn't
until i moved out because we couldn't
afford internet
and well we had internet we just i just
didn't know it we could have hopped on
dsl
but
i wasn't like
i'm not a super big star wars dude i
love the way that the characters are
designed and stuff like that but i'm not
no star wars cat like that but here's
what i know i know that that game when
it dropped it really made waves attic i
don't know if you're old enough to
remember but um i know you remember g4
but when that game rolled out they was
like no this is it like this is the
definitive like online thing because i
think that you could have chose the
light side and then you could have chose
the dark side maybe it was just like it
was an mmo you could play it for so long
and a lot of people were so big on it
and
you know when i saw it when i know i
think the cog was like you know mr
maddie plays a loser's mind when he saw
and i think he did cause i think he did
a video on it i was like cool that's
cool but you know um it's
it surprised me that playstation got
that because i i do remember that being
on the og xbox and i don't think it was
anywhere else i might be wrong on that
but i remember that being the xbox thing
i remember that being like the online
thing and that's what you had to be to
go play it so i mean i'm i'm cool with
it i'm always cool for like the remakes
you know just to get like a new audience
because it's it's been however long it's
been it's been over a decade 15 years
right so it's always cool to see like
the
old fans like connect with like new fans
i'm like hey this is how we used to do
it back in the day like that's that's
always like a cool thing to see that's a
part of game preservation and with me
you'll know that i'm super big on that
anyway but it's cool to see um is do we
know when this game is going to xbox or
game pass at all um there's like
conflicting stuff that you might never
come to game pass so
oh i mean xbox in general i don't know
like i don't think we've had anything
like definitive about it yet
but i i am interested if it does go
because to me
let me drag this chat over here so i can
see what's going on but to me like what
it comes down to
is it's not even like what it's coming
to or what it's not coming to is
what are they making like who's making
it that that's the biggest thing to me
because to me
i i care more about the studio making
that i care about the actual studio if
that makes sense to you i mean than the
actual game because
look i'm not saying aspar or i i
definitely butchered you
aspire like i'm not saying they're a bad
studio i'm not by any means but i am
saying that like when it comes to
certain things i am curious
if they are up to the task to make
something as iconic as star wars couture
that's a big franchise we can't act like
it's not
and to me like
it's equivalent let's say you know this
game is that important to me okay it's
that important to me
imagine
if before god of war 2018 was launched
imagine if they
decided that they were going to
let a random company you've never heard
of made it you know what i'm saying
how would you feel about that like to me
i love this franchise and i'm scared
that this company
isn't going to give it the justice that
i want
and okay until i see
physical proof until i see a certain
scenario in certain game play aspects i
can't 100 percent before this remake
i can't be hyped for it because i don't
know how this game's gonna come out
okay um i believe i looked up the
correct spelling of these names kind of
uh aspire so here are the games that
they did make um star wars
republic commando for playstation and
switch
a game called uh rwby i don't know if
that's ruby or rwby grim
eclipse
and that's on the switch um they made
star wars jedi knight jedi academy i
have heard of that one um on playstation
and nintendo switch
they made star wars wait a minute star
wars jedi knight two
jedi okay that's one playstation the
switch and a game you may be familiar
with stubs the zombie
have you ever heard of that no
all right well i i i figured you were
familiar i i assumed you were familiar
with the more you talk about it the more
i'm getting nervous
okay and they also made civilization six
on mobile
on ios to be exact i think this is the
ios symbol
well well you know i i want to do my
best
give me that link and put it put it in
the chat so the chat can see it put it
in the chat oh sure thing hold on here i
go
yeah
i was just interested to take a look um
see what they made so they got a few but
they do have a few star wars titles here
so i mean that's you know promising we
i'll go back and take a look at to see
how those games performed and what we
can all have through that you know off
camera and everything but it's probably
going to have a little history
and it's like i said in no way shape or
form
is this attacking the studio because
it's not
yeah but
it's just like look like i'm just
nervous
that something that i i grew up with
isn't going to
live up to the height that in my head i
deserve it meets you know what i'm
saying like and to me like let's see
like it's like i said imagine if
saint monica didn't make god of war 2018
and these people did would you be
nervous
i don't do that don't do that but it's a
legitimacy
i understand no i i understand um i
think you just probably wanted one of
the big boys to yeah i wanted like yeah
no i'll get you if they said bio were
made up like let's go
but they didn't like
and if you look at this man like star
wars commando like you know let's click
on this real quick
you know let's
let's make sure it's muted
like
that's that's no i mean i guess you
but it said a remake like to me i'm
feeling like couture is just gonna be on
another level you know what i'm saying
like
yeah i mean they made a switch version
okay we got a star wars switch game
nights uh the jedi academy
you know
you know maybe maybe like
i can't say nothing about the studio
because at the end of the day it's nice
they're getting the opportunity
and indeed you know
sometimes
you know like we say an iop sometimes
you just got to give these little people
a chance you know what i'm saying and
once you give these little people a
chance you'd be surprised in what kind
of product they make but i do i feel
like to me personally because i enjoy
this franchise and i love this franchise
so much that i do have the right to just
be like please don't mess this up like
like because i would be so
nervous but you know
but before we move on i want to
acknowledge duncan's self in the chat he
said those are remasters this is a
remake also bioware aren't good now i'm
going to censor myself he's not wrong
bioware may anthem correct
[Music]
oh boy shout out to my girlflow hugger
over there level one i think she's the
only person who we know i think she's
the only one who likes that game so
shout out to my shout out to my wife
flow hug that my baby but yeah bioware
they aren't really themselves so well
they are their former selves and i say
that and i do say that with all due
respect by the way so you know i mean i
guess we can just wait and see um what's
the next game on the list kind sir
project eve
okay
we can we can kind of we can project eve
we talked we briefly talked about a
little bit
okay but it looked too much like
platinum games and i was wanting to
throw up the whole time i was watching
this like
i'm just not a
platinum games fan and i like it looks
so platinum-y to me like what did you
feel
well as a person who doesn't typically
play platinum games i liked what they
showed here
to the protagonist i don't know if her
name is eve would assume her name is eve
she looked cool to me like she legit not
sexy but like cool she looked like an
actual cool character she looked like a
badass and i you know i welcome i
welcome that i welcome like the some of
the gameplay they show you know it's
cool like i said it reminded me of devil
may cry and
i hope that you know it's done some type
of justice uh we spoke on it earlier you
know certain people are kind of certain
people have their own opinions on the
matter
i didn't look at this young lady as just
being sexy or anything i just looked at
her as just being like
cool
like she looked like she like
what is people talking about because i
didn't even remotely sexualize this
woman whatsoever so i guess that's why
like that caught me off guard when it
was being talked about someone did bring
up vanquish i guess maybe it gave them a
vanquish feeling i never played vanquish
but it gave me a platinum feeling and i
automatically was waiting for this
commercial this this this trailer to be
over the one when i saw and that's not a
bad thing platinum actually is a really
good game it's just i'm tired of their
games um that's just me personally uh
but so
you think you know that this was a
highlight of playstation show because i
feel like you know going into a couture
was a highlight
i i do feel like that's a good way of
starting it most people don't know
that you know that studio is making and
they're not like i want to make sure
we're not saying nothing bad about the
studio we're just saying that a studio a
game such as that caliber
i'm nervous that a studio that haven't
really made games like that or a triple
a
style like that is making that's the
only issue i had with that but as far as
project eve do you think this was like
like you your eyes were on the screen
the whole time how did you feel when you
saw this
it was cool one point for me one point
for playstation as far as i know
i know it's i know it's a third-party
game and everything but yeah i'm not
gonna lie
you know and i'm not even the xbox dude
but that would have been dope if xbox
works will have owned something like
that in my opinion just you know just
based off of what we saw but it was cool
like i i enjoyed that trail a lot i look
forward to trying that out at some given
point in time
pc of course but know that that that
look like that look cool to me and i
hope the gameplay here is as good as
good as that trailer was all the
gameplay hit all right so number three
tiny tina's wonderlands how did you feel
about this game did it do anything for
you like i actually like this tiny tina
play more than i like that project eve i
was i was a little more
like because i i like borderlands it's
an okay franchise uh i but you know it i
really enjoyed what i saw how did you
feel when you saw tying a team
yeah that's a big skip for me dog i
ain't really that's borderland that's
that's randy pitchford that's that's
that crew over there gearbox right
i'm cool i'm cool i'm cool with that but
but i never really been a fan of
borderlands like there anyway i think
it's dope that you know one of the
um what's the word
it's dope that uh
you know the one of the
love most beloved characters got a spin
off so i got the uncharted like lowest
legacy vibes not in terms of gameplay
but just like a beloved character like
this is like the chloe probably to like
that universe possibly if i'm making
that comparison if i'm wrong y'all let
me know of course but it's cool that
they got that that own little spin over
here what they show was cool but i'm not
interested man that's that's a big skip
for me you gotta tell me how that plays
cause i know cause i heard you doing the
reaction well yeah you seem like big on
that so i'm interested to hear from you
cause i'm this i'm good on that one man
i really enjoyed what i played on um
on borderlands 3. was it the greatest
game in the world no but i do think it
was
it was it was entertaining uh so we do
got to fight all the super chat records
i'll let you read that because it's
addressing you
yeah from uh the homie gerald mack man
oh let's highlight this so i can see
the hustle and motivate acquisition to
the lord addicts show is just as big
as lord cognito to the dukes great pick
salute you are far too kind don't you
over don't over sell me like that
i appreciate it
hey
thank you
yeah i wasn't expecting to hear that
today we'll go ahead and we'll get to to
to to probably one of the highlights of
the show to me
it's from
what was your thought process when you
saw this man what was going through
hustle's mind
so this is about done by square enix um
for spoken has not looked bad since the
moment that we saw it it has never
looked bad in fact it's getting better
over time like
um
the gentleman who made the comments
about uh project eve can kind of compare
that to this game that we're speaking
about now
i understand
his complaint and i understand like
we're in a different time and you know
more characters should be like the young
lady that we saw but you know it just is
what it is and i don't want to harp back
on that but i didn't want to bring that
up as a point um this is this is another
character who looks cool to me um
i'm not even a square enix dude like
that like i don't really you know it was
super mario rpg final fantasy 3 and
that's about it man but this is um
you know in luminous i think i think the
studio's name luminous production so i
wanna make sure i get that right
yeah um
it looks good
this this looks really good the gameplay
looked fun i'm not gonna lie that
gameplay looked fun um i think one of
the things i think i addressed said it's
the king i said yo i want to see a bunch
of enemies on the screen and we kind of
got that a little bit and i said let's
see if that frame rate dipped because i
mean you know i love them frames boy but
um because i'll be playing this on
playstation first so i just want to make
sure that the performance is there the
game looks really fun but this game has
always looked funny from the moment that
we saw it and um
i think um
they may have something with for spoken
i say square but i think both of the uh
the publisher and the developer they may
have something in a new like
ip and they may have something special
here only time will tell though only
time will tell so we got another five
dollar super chat from the iron lures
podcast it was funniest
i didn't super chat myself okay let's
call it okay so you can read the super
chat because he's addressing you too
okay
all righty alrighty uh good to see
hustle on addict's show all right
my first round oh my god sir don't do
that okay my first round draft pick make
sure wait a
minute uh make sure you let
make sure he let you get your bars off
make sure he lets you get your balls up
just joking a lot of stuff
thank you well cognito
yeah it would have been for me just
just get up rub me there you know how
easy it would have been for me to uh
super chat and just put cog at the end
of it and act like people love me
[Laughter]
magneto you're still watching cognito
how do you like the new background man
because i had to put it to what it was
just so you could see it real quick
yeah go ahead and address cognito
man call me the first round draft pick
hey hey look man
big words
now i gotta live up to it now that's all
but i you know y'all know y'all know
what it is we spoke behind the scenes
and i tell you
publicly
the opportunities dog opportunities and
abundance you'll see me tweet it out
i'm happy to be here let's make history
uh that's it and uh everybody in the
chat yo real quick since we all talking
about that thank you all for such for
for the kind words man like seriously
because i know how that was i know how
that tweet was gonna go addict i know
how i was gonna go
what i saw it the good thing about iop
man is oh boy you know i love our
community but at the end of the day this
is the attic show i don't care where
that tweet was going you were still
coming
i appreciate it i appreciate it no no no
that's that's the stupid though what do
you think about for spoken sir what do
you think what i have to say about this
folk
oh yeah i'm not saying this game's not
going to be bad
i'm not saying this game doesn't have
potential from what i'm seeing all i'm
seeing is it feels like
final fantasy
16 or 15 part two that they just renamed
it for spoken and they just gave it a
new name because it's just like it gives
me such
final fantasy vibes but it doesn't have
a final fantasy on there like
i feel like the female that's like the
female version of of noctis
like i i don't i don't know like
i have to see it and i'm not saying this
game ain't going to be good because like
i i do feel like the the studio's got
potential and they could do what they
could do what they do it but at the end
of the day it's just like i got to see
more like we don't see a whole lot of
people fighting on the screen at the
same time either so like it makes me
real like you know that was that was a
quick oh i'm interrupting you i
apologize go ahead go ahead so it does
make me like nervous on what type of
gameplay we're going to get with this
i did like some of the special effects
we got i thought those were pretty good
and i'm not saying like you know 15 was
okay
uh i do feel like in terms of final
fantasy i'm a huge final fantasy fan i
felt like it was a step in the right
direction
but it wasn't
getting final fantasy back to its full
form or glory you know what i'm saying
but you know maybe for spoken is going
to give them different
aspects to get them in the right
direction you know uh you know like you
know like we said getting
unique perspectives you know we got a uh
we got a black uh protagonist so you
know having that type of perspective
might bring some more into it just in
general
i just want a more unique final fantasy
because to me something's got to change
final fantasy i feel like personally
he's been going downhill every
week every installment since 10.
and i'm hoping that maybe this is what
we need and you know i i'm digging the
new the main character i am i i feel
like you know that aspect of coming from
the from the past coming to the uh to
this fantasy world cool
is just can they actually execute that
that's a huge question we don't know if
they can do that hey addict real quick
before we move on um it looks like they
put all the budget into the main
character who's extremely she's
beautiful i don't know who's i want to
know who like who her model is but
i i was watching the video as the
trailer as we're talking um oh boy
yeah this looks they put all the budget
into the main character i'll and i'll
leave it at that that's that's what it
seemed like to me because i see other
npcs
oh boy it's looking spooky like october
31st of this joint that they look it
look crazy some some of them look crazy
and i won't i won't say well you'll see
it you'll be like okay yeah there's a
definite like
budget restriction as a term i'm not
even going to say the minimum because i
don't want to be disrespectful but
there's definitely a uh
a thing hey um real quick shout out to
gaming14 in the chat man
thank you i appreciate your kind word
sir you always been there
thank y'all again y'all making this real
easy for you boy man y'all making me
feel like i'm at home boy thank y'all
man thank you guys thank you guys
man
i can honestly say that
i love the iop community you know uh
the amount of people that we've gotten
together is is just
it's just crazy how
giving the community's always been
throughout the years you know
everything you see here the new camera i
got a new pc i don't know a lot of you
don't know that but i got a new pc to
help do these streams more efficiently
because uh i don't know if you guys
noticed but when we did the
uh
whatever jeff keeley thinks called the
the
the online games
yeah whatever that's called you that was
my stream that crashed that wasn't cogs
that was mine so we was we was done with
that we got a new pc for me and all that
is because of the generosity and the
viewership and the likes that you guys
get you guys get our uh you guys coming
in and you hit that like button
considering we we do have 150 people hit
that like button might as well get that
in there since talking about the likes
so you know you guys get our our
podcasts and better algorithms you come
up for the attic shows the iops come up
to the kos's you super chat you go into
the patreon you go on the members we've
been trying to do better with the people
that you know financially give us stuff
we we appreciate everyone and we have
been trying to do better with the people
that you know uh super chat and stuff
because no lord receives a dime out of
the money that comes into iop goes back
into the bank account and when we get
stuff like you know new cameras uh
because all the lords have this camera
we'll have hopefully theirs will be up
in the next couple weeks
uh you know every camera's gonna look
like this i'm not the only one that's
supposed to look look i know you guys
might think that we bought the i have
the only nice camera because of this
beard that's not the case like
everyone's got the camera and everyone
will get that camera uh hooked up in the
next couple weeks just people busy man
car doing like 15 shows a week he's a
busy dude he's doing help he does a lot
he does a lot with the website you know
king is doing king stuff constantly uh
you know he stayed on twitter 24 7. uh
it solved works like 18 jobs and you
know
it's it's hard to because
i was the guinea pig with the cameras i
know how to set the cameras up so
but it's hard to find a good time for me
and the other lord to sit down and
really build the camera because this is
not easy this is like 18 different parts
to set this camera up
don't i know it don't know what that was
well i was one of the first ones to to
have it but
definitely yeah oh i went there but
let's get back to the show let's get
back to this this playstation goodness
here that a lot of playstation fans are
the ones who i rock with that wasn't too
big on it man um the next game on this
list which was the big skip for me
rainbow six extraction
why pass why
i'm not saying that this isn't a good
thing
i'm just saying why was it here
yes yeah y'all when we when we saw it i
was we i think we all had that like look
like look listen i get it you gotta you
gotta appease your third parties but
man look i i saw that during the ubisoft
show and i'm glad we didn't televise
that one boy we oh now that was ugly but
i was like yo i didn't
i didn't care then i don't care now and
man look i'm i'm good
i'm good on that man and i and i'm gonna
be extremely respectful when saying that
they doing anything i ain't this this
game shouldn't even exist i'm gonna be
real with you
like i i don't know why i'm not saying
talk they have killed it with rainbow
six siege but i didn't talk i played so
much rainbow six siege you know what
never has happened hustle i've never
talked to someone and they're like yo i
want i want a game where we play against
aliens and stuff not one time not one
time
i get it there's probably a demographic
for this and there's probably people
that's going to play this you know who's
going to play this hustle people that
are bored
this should have been an update into
into rainbow six siege that gives you an
extra mode
but instead they want to they want to
bundle this up and and put a big red
bull on it
and put it on there and say we're going
to pay us 60 bones for it i think it's
60 i don't know if it is uh they don't
have any prices here so don't don't
quote me on that but all right i just
feel like you shouldn't have been there
before we go before we move on um it
releases in january of 2022 so if you
guys are looking forward to that
y'all you tweet me and you let me know
how it is because boy i i'm good
i'm good um the next game on the list is
uh the alan wake remaster
um i skipped allen wake on the 360
because uh they had a lot of screen
tearing in it and i kind of wasn't
interested in the uh pro tag it really
wasn't wasn't my cup of tea um
but this this remake looked really good
when we saw it i know a lot a lot of
people are like nah it don't look good i
think it's cool like it's it's cool it's
cool for what it is um
hopefully they fix a lot of whatever
areas errors were in the last game i
hope they fix it in this one and it's
updated and everything just works out to
uh to work in that favor um
i'm always cool i'm cool with the remake
as long as they fix and adjust and
honestly i kind of even though i'm not
interested i hope enough people buy this
game so remedy can make a sequel
let me roll with you i ain't playing at
all awake i got no plans on playing out
like every time i look at alan wake i
want to i want to get a good big big
giant baby and go to sleep
[Laughter]
uh i'm not saying the game isn't bad i
know it's a classic it's not classic to
me
so uh sorry not sorry i'm not playing i
don't care about it uh when this came up
i i acknowledged that uh what looked the
worst is this was an xbox related game
it was heavily connected to xbox and
it's on a playstation showcase so i
think that was the worst part about it
but as far as
being a game
i i'm gonna be real with you remedy is
up there with platinum games with me
i'm not really feeling remedy games i
felt like control
was it was a a huge average ass game and
people blew that game out of proportion
to me i'm not saying it was a bad game
i'm just saying the only thing i ever
heard people talk about is levitating
and throwing stuff at people
i never really see people talk about the
story i never see people talk about
anything related to control besides
shooting people and throwing stuff at
people
so to me i could never feel like that
type of game
is like
that extra if that's the only things
that people could really say
uh but you know clearly you yourself you
you're interested in
and uh alan wake it looks like so uh you
know is this something because you've
seen on it would you try it on your pc
or ps5 or xbox series x
yeah and maybe it's not like a day one
thing but maybe it's if i'm in between
games you know my stream i'm streaming
uncharted numeracy and stuff like that
so if i'm in between games i'll try just
to see if i like it and you know the
great thing about steam is if i don't
like it within two hours then you know
that thing
i'm going to take that road trip no jack
move johnny you understand me that thing
but no that's only if it's only if i
don't find it intriguing or anything but
like i'm cool for remakes like i said i
hope it remedies pardon the pun all the
issues with the last one and i'm sure
that it will and if it sells well you
know we can it could be like the crash
bandicoot 4 of whatever this is whatever
the you know alan wake series is so
yeah i mean i'll try i'll definitely try
it i'm going to bury what you uh uh fam
alawake
got i don't even think i'd play if it
was given to me
i don't think i played if it was in game
pass
i think if i saw it in game pass i would
be annoyed they wasted an announcement
putting that game pass
well i'm just it's just not for me man i
get it a lot of people love that game
and i'm glad that a lot of people get
this and i'm sure if alan wake 2 came
out it's going to be in playstation 5
exclusive that's going to be funny to
see on twitter
uh but you know i hope it does because
at the end of the day i want all games
to succeed it's just
the game doesn't appeal to me so
our next one
is gta 5 expanded and enhanced edition
slash gta online
how do you feel about knowing that we've
seen gta 5
for damn near a decade
well
i know it's my my first day and
everything i have to apologize to the
audience because this is my fault i
bought this game on ps3
i brought this game on ps4
and yes
i brought this game yes i brought this
game on pc i'm looking for the game i
don't think i have it i don't think i
have it anymore on ps and i don't think
i got it no more no i don't have any
more but i bought this game three times
i have this game for free on the epic
game store as well
and i will be getting this game on ps4
i'm sorry i'm sorry i'm sorry um now we
speak about the
uh enhanced edition i didn't see any
enhancements that joint still looked
like it was running at 30. but maybe the
trailer maybe the stream itself was
running that 30 whatever i'll forgive it
now um i don't know who came up with
this phrase but i'm gonna take it today
is that we can't keep letting them get
away with this now i know i can't do the
voice and i can't do all that but we
rockstar got to stop addict did you see
the uh the trailer on the playstation uh
did you did you see the grand theft auto
5 trailer on the playstation channel
that but that that dislike ratio crazy
boy that's that thing like what's funny
is people are going people companies are
going to see that before they see
anything else
uh
from gamer by choice game of the year
gta 5.
look man
i might have to block you for that one
no joke i don't check look i there's a
lot of people that's going to like this
uh i probably will pick it up
well i haven't played the story since
the 360.
and
i didn't buy it for pc so i i'm one i'm
one below you right now i bought it for
xbox one and i bought it for the 360 i
did not buy it for pc so if i buy it for
the piece uh for the series x i feel
like it's going to balance the force a
little bit
uh so you know it is what it is i don't
think gta 5 being announced is bad i do
think that a company taking time to
announce this is an l but i don't think
it'd be an announcement bad i think that
should have been like a youtube video or
something like that
yeah um i'll say this before we before
we finish here um
gta 5 ain't trash if y'all played the
story because i yo i i had it on ps3 i
played and beat that story in like four
days like that that game was is fire i
love that game i love single player
online not so much but
look look we we're in a situation now to
where like this is like elder scrolls i
want to take y'all back to the ps2 era
we got five gta games
that era gta 3
vice city san andreas fight city stories
liberty city stories we also got liberty
city stories and vice city stories for
the psp now granted i know that those
reports over but it don't matter dog
like it don't matter like the output of
work that they felt like that rockstar
had to do and i know that it's quicker
to make those games than it is to make
this one i i know i i know don't please
don't hit me with that i know about the
game development i know i know but it's
the thought
last generation we only got two gta
games gta 4
and the behemoth known as gta 5. i got a
theory about gta 5 before i finish i
think they're going to hit 200 million
and that's when they go and ease their
foot up off the gas and the online is
going to carry over to gta 6.
in my humble opinion i think that's what
they're going for because they're
already in the guinness book of world
records from what i understand so this
thing
it's definitely a thing man um
rockstar get that money
like
y'all unstoppable they
they they're the juggernaut of the whole
joint though like grand theft auto 5 at
this point should come with all the
consoles it's like now here you go
now here
they go they had a ups man just knocking
the door here you go rockstar just did
not just take it play the online
and
i'd say and you know what really quick
before before i finish up today credit
they're online they've been really
updating online and really like
servicing like their community so that's
that's definitely like i can't even
really say it's dope for them because
like that's beneficially
better for them to do that because at
the end of the day like
it's not like they were making like this
out of the kindness of their heart
they're making content to make you to
grind or buy shark cards
to get that content so like like to me
it's it makes it even bad because they
focused on that and they didn't even
focus on story at all
so like
like look man like they being a little
bit greedy man like you're making all
that money and you felt like you
couldn't do any story dlc at all you
know what i'm saying
yeah they missed that and that's a
mystery by the way because i wanted that
dlc i wanted to see how franklin trevor
and mike get after after the events of
it a spoiler alert this game came out
almost 10 years ago
i don't want i look if it's
no no you you could spoil man spoiler or
gta 5.
all right so you had three different
then this you could have killed michael
you could have killed trevor as franklin
of course or you could have picked the
third way which was the death wish and
that was that's the actual ending you
you do whatever heist that you do
you have to pretty much fight your way
out of everybody who had beef with
everybody else which i'm not gonna get
into cool cool game dope in there
um it even carries on after the fact
depending on which ending that you pick
however
yeah dlc was needed much needed
yeah it was it was much needed the story
dlc rather the story dlc was was
definitely needed and this
added this my fault
i kept buying the game dawg i can't buy
it i did i don't know what it's like i
said i bought it twice so what we're
gonna do because i we don't really got
time to go through all these we're going
to go through the highlights all right
ghost wire tokyo do you think they
should have been here i feel like they
didn't really reveal anything new
uh i get it it's their game but it's
like it's been delayed
uh they they're having death luke come
out so why did you even waste time on
this game
yeah it didn't need to be there that was
something that hey we've kind of already
seen before i don't think that there was
anything new in that trailer from from
even that xbox show somebody nothing new
but again the reason why i was there
because i wasn't in the room that this
event was supposed to take place around
the e3 for their for playstation's e3
replacement or e3 like
slotted programming
but if that is the case then i get why
it's there but it shouldn't have been
i'll just be real with you
that wouldn't i'm cool it was definitely
now i felt like guardians of the galaxy
marvel's guards of the galaxy
i don't even like what i see on this
game so
i'm gonna say this this needed this
needed to stay wherever it was before it
came on here
i i
every time i see this i get less and
less like intrigued on the franchise
how did you feel
that that's a big skip that's a big
skill i'm cool on that it's just
that to me look i ain't gonna find when
i when we saw the phone we first saw
like the mom when i first saw that
marvel splash screen i said oh
spider-man and then i was like nah nah
homie
nope
so now i'm good i'm starting i'm good
all right respectfully respectfully
vampires the masquerade probably
butchered that blood hunt
l
shouldn't have been here
nothing about this i can almost
guarantee you 80 of the people watching
this did not come out at the end of this
trailer let's see let me go download
bloodhound
did you come out with that thought
process
i'm gonna keep betrayal with you i
didn't even remember this drawing peeing
there
respect and i say that was
yeah i remember it like it was
yo never mind i'm good i'm uh i'll i'll
pass on this one death i'll pass on this
one
all right well that's luther's they
didn't we didn't need to see that we we
listen the promotion for death loop has
been insane hey look shout out to today
team for for doing that but we've seen
def loop
for a long time
i'm surprised you're not burnt out on it
man and you're playing it now so i'm
surprised you're not burnt down on it
but it's you know whatever i don't see
and stuff but like i don't want to see
no more of it uh are you looking at the
death loop screen
well uh what we were saying i didn't
click on the video no no i didn't like
the screen just like what's showing on
top of it death loop down the rabbit
hole
but anyway uh
yeah oh no i didn't i didn't look at it
oh it's fine uh so we're gonna we're
gonna skip some of these like indie
games because i know a lot of people
don't necessarily care about that
especially my viewership we're going to
talk about
the one
the only
uncharted legacy of these collection
coming to pc
how you guys feel about that
well been eating these so i beat one of
these already i beat uh abila's legacy
um uncharted 4. i'm not going to start
until they put it on pc and it's
scheduled to be on pc and playstation 5.
i think playstation 5 first and that's
early 2022 so i'm looking forward to
that there was an interesting
find on digital foundry um alex patelia
i hope i got his name right
he pretty much was like yo they was like
hey alex did you notice any differences
it was like i was at a frame rate he
pretty much said outside the frame rate
it looked like it was at 1440p now i
don't care about that i just want to
join to run at a high frame rate because
i saw i'm playing all the uncharted
games for the very first time but that's
dope um i beat lost legacy anytime i see
my girl chloe man you know i'm a baby
that that that's that's my baby right
there so
anytime we can we get to run back
through it we going to do that um
i'm happy i know a lot of people aren't
happy and i saw some reactions from from
people
they're not happy about the whole
playstation and pc thing but
all right look i will keep it real with
you you got to accept the inevitable at
this point you got to it's over all this
stuff whole slate gang we saw like a
news a news wire rumored like newswire
about uncharted 4 just coming to pc
and i said well why why is it just that
one and i thought we was going to get
the whole thing because rumors were
leading up to it about the whole
uncharted thing somebody did an awful
thumbnail shout out to them about the
uncharted collection and it did the
whole thing right
i'm happy this you asked me last week
what would save the show for me this is
what shaved the show i'm not gonna lie
so how do i talk about some other stuff
how did you feel about that pc
oh you already know what type of time
i'm on sir listen i love it i love all
of it i'm about to join i'm gonna grab
that i thought a little joint i'm about
on ps5 and i'm going by to get on pc i'm
sorry
i'm not sorry but you know whatever i
want that
i really
chloe chloe nadine and sam they they
need to be in uncharted five and i'm
going to show all my support like now
you make them the main characters you
leave drake's daughter out of it you put
them in the next one you put her in the
next one right but you leave her out of
it but you you make sure that the three
the three people who i just mentioned
chloe being in club would be my baby you
got to put you got to put him up on the
forefront because like that that
adventure was too short sam comes about
halfway in the middle of it i'm not
going to get into it it's a really good
game though good games will always be
good games and they'll always get my
support how'd you feel about it daddy
you got to let me know man
so we've got to fight out super chat
from gamer by uh choice i like that name
gamer by choice
i refreshed the screen and just saw an
ad for guardians of the galaxy they're
trying to get that money look man
they're gonna need us they're gonna need
more than just a couple ads because when
i see that game i'm not like excited
whatsoever i mean maybe though that
would change yeah they better launch
that like when there ain't nothing out
to play like at all so all right all
right this is what we're gonna do hustle
uh we're gonna talk about wolverine
okay and spider-man at the same time
because i i feel like you know they're
made by insomniac
first off i want to ask you and people
in the chat feel free to put your
opinions in the chat do you think
insomniac
is their best studio
no
not yet now yet now yet most consistent
uh i make this comparison i did a video
about the last seven years with
insomniac and the output of work that
they're doing they're doing amazing work
they are yes yeah yes indeed they are
but they've always done amazing work
don't get me wrong
naughty dog man long as we got one of
these last of us part one as you know is
my second favorite game of all time
first favorite game of all time you know
what it's uncharted two
it's uncharted two for me but
not yet not yet but i'm not i'm not
going live when we saw that trailer when
when we saw the trailer for spider-man
we know it's going to look like that
based off of what miles morales did when
we saw that trailer for i
look it's a few companies who can get
away with showing trailers they can show
another trailer and i'm still good
because we know the gameplay gonna hit
for something different we know that the
visuals are gonna be what the visuals
are but are they the best studio nah man
naughty dog man naughty dog there's a
reason
there is a reason why naughty dog is so
high on that list for me is that charter
series i have not played last of us two
yet but from what i understand outside
of the the gruesomeness gameplay is on
point man so we gotta you know
we look it's gonna it's gonna take a lot
from me to the throne naughty dog is
that number one because of the feelings
that i have toward last of us one and
uncharted i think i'm trying to
seriously as a whole right now i'm
having fun i'm having a great time
playing one two and three
and we lost legacy i beat already so
like i'm just i'm having a great time so
right now
naughty dog is here but i'm not going
live they if they're not careful and i'm
sure they will be
zombie ag is like right here sona santa
monica's got all right
it's a good competition over there let
me just say that let me say that there's
a really good competition going on in
that playstation cam man you ain't going
people ain't like what i'm about to say
okay sonic's the third best studio
oh okay i feel like look
insomniac is their most efficient studio
they make the best quality for the
amount of time they put in but until
they make a game that's on caliber of
last of us or god of war they can't beat
those games
to me the best studio makes the best
games they don't make the most
consistent good games they make the best
games and look at the end of the day
spider-man was a great game it was not
on last of us or
or god of war caliber it wasn't uh you
know and that's just how it is uh to me
when it comes to
their best studio in my personal opinion
it's saint monica
and then
and then it's insomniac and that's not
saying insomniac you know i got to see
one game that's on that level it don't
even have to be better just one game
that's on that level and to me you can't
say just because they can make more
games
if they don't like one game that's on
that level why does it matter if they
can make multiple games in a matter of a
couple years if they don't make one game
that's on the last of us level
to me god of war and last of us are on
the same level i don't know about you
hustle but i feel like those type of
quality games sure they're different
appeals to different crowds but you
could consider those on the same type of
level in terms of quality
i will okay so about three and a half
hours in god of war 2018. i'll say this
about a naughty dog and i want to
mention something about insomnia what
naughty dog has managed to do for me
personally it's just
it really wasn't it wasn't the gameplay
it was really the story now
um
this new spider-man spider-man 2
apparently this room meant to have more
like mature themes
and i kind of know what that means like
i could kind of read between the lines
on that one
and i won't even say but
yeah apparently it's supposed to have
like a stronger like mature thing now
i'm not saying it's rated mature i'm
saying that it'll have like a stronger
theme apparently things are supposed to
be a little bit more brutal and a little
bit more grotesque allegedly this is
what things are floating around the
float around the ether so i look forward
to that now i'll say this
if inside me i can pull off a great
story and then uh i'm not gonna lie
you know the two studios you mentioned
might be in a little
might be in a little trouble yes good
trouble though wolverine comes out and
spider-man 2 comes out like look
we don't really
give a lot of power to metacritic but
the industry does so we can't act like
the industry doesn't
they haven't made a game that's on that
caliber they haven't made a 90 rated
above game like ever
like i think it's like the since like
the original like ratchet and clank or
something like that like one of those
and that was like a 2004 or 2005 like
and i'm not trying to give all this
power to metacritic but it's just like
what metacritic is
at its core is just
pretty much an average score of all of
the reviews in the industry and you've
got to give some form of validation to
that but there's there's a lot of gaps
in a lot of loopholes in terms of
metacritic like how
they write three out of fives as a six
out of ten like you know none of that
makes any sense but at the end of the
day
they gotta have that type of game they
got to have a 90 plus better credit like
they just got to like for me to even
consider them their best studio like
sure i will give them they're their most
efficient studio and they are literally
got the biggest backpack in all of
playstation is on that [ __ ] right now
but as far as their best studio i can't
give that to them
it's
you know um
i i'll say this before we get on to i
think wolverine is gonna hit a little
different i think if it's based off of
the movie it's definitely gonna hit a
little different it's gonna have a story
it's gonna be a little bit more mature
too
i'm i'm excited and it's rumor this is
speculation well well let's say it's
rumor it's speculation on my part that
they are connecting these universes i
keep hearing that going around and if
they do that
then i think we know what insomniac will
do going forward with that marvel
universe man if even if let's say all
the games are 85 i would have
uh
eight nine ten eighty fives didn't have
to wait on like one or two nineties one
or two ninety five even a ninety six i
would i would much have rather have that
consistency there because there's always
something good to play and you know what
you're gonna get with it but i'm just
gonna be real with you man it's
things are looking up and shout out to
insomniac they
boy they they put they they put their
hard hat on man
all the teams over there they put their
shout out to them i'm looking forward to
wolverine in particular i'm definitely
looking forward to spiderman too i beat
miles morales
and oh you saw my boy miles in there
it's not going to be co-op i was
speculating that was going to be co-op
it's not going to be co-op but that's
that's going to be dope but um
yeah yeah i can't wait for that man
that's that's something i'm looking
forward to i don't think we need to talk
about gran turismo are you a grand
trisman fan
no but it looked nice okay we could skip
that that's fine we could skip that that
never showed up to me i'm gonna be real
with you let's talk about spiderman
because we only got god of war after
that
um okay for some reason people
were so i was gonna say we kind of
discussed that right i'm sorry my fault
like for some reason i want to talk
about people being surprised that
spider-man was there like i get it
you're surprised because it's like the
amount of length since the last one and
i'm not even really like
i guess we would have to go for miles
but to me miles is a smaller project
than a full-flown sequel you know what
i'm saying so like yeah to me the amount
of people working on that was probably
small
so i'm going off of what i see currently
and to me
2018 is when spider-man came out
so that's when i
started the countdown 18 19 20 21 20 uh
three for you that sounds about right
yeah
yeah i mean no argument here that that
on that to me like i could see people
being you know
hyped that it's there but like did you
expect it not to be there in any way
shape or form hustle
i think we spoke about that i was i was
almost certain that it would have been
there
oh man the way that the media hyped this
thing up on twitter and social media i
definitely expected that to be there um
i didn't think that we would get a venom
reveal and hey i didn't know if you
noticed but when we all were together
that um
somebody said they heard a craving
the whole time
oh okay okay yeah see and i'm not
familiar with the uh i know king he was
putting me up on game a little bit
he he mentioned the uh the multiverse
so i'm i don't want to spoil it but i
hear something does happen to somebody
i'm gonna say who but i think if you
know the multiverse you kind of know
what happens but i'll just say man um
is it
tony todd is his name
i don't know
the gentleman who voices venom
he's done an extremely like good job a
lot of people are like really receptive
to him people was really excited that he
was playing venom
yep that's another question
let's say that you do assume
let's say tuesday came around and
someone told you yo
spider-man's going to be at this event
did you expect venom there
yeah only that's what i was saying like
i don't understand how people were so
surprised that venom was in a spider-man
game you know what i'm saying like well
well i would say if i i didn't beat 2018
but i did beat miles morales like at the
end of the end credits they
they got harry osborn
at the end of end credits you know venom
is the thing let me just say that let me
chill i mean that because i don't even
want to get out of the way i want to let
y'all play that but you know that that
venom is the thing
i just didn't
oh i need to be careful
is a better game than the original
spider-man that was me though i got
butchered for that conversation but you
know it is what it is let's go to god
award
all righty
was you disappointed in what you saw
depending on the expectations and the
hype that was in your mind
no
one thousand percent there um i said
this last week we knew that they were
going to be there if they wouldn't have
been there boy twitter would have been
on fire
um i don't care if people call this a
quote-unquote dlc i don't i don't care i
just want a good game to be a good game
um we didn't get a release year on it
this game
well we know it's going to run at a
higher frame rate than the other one if
the other one had ability the way you
could choose the frame rates and all
that on a ps4 pro and it's not a lock 60
that's that in the third you know that
this one gonna run at 60 at least
atres man that boy been doing his
push-ups right that boy got big cause he
got big and he wants to know more about
his origin man i'm i'm with it uh like i
said i'm i'm definitely with it um
i i got a question after you give your
thoughts and everything on it
do you think kratos is going soft at all
let's just curious you know kratos uh a
trance is leading the one who wants to
know more about who he is he said i
don't need you to be a dad i need you to
be a general and he says no
oh
sir
this ain't the cradles
i know a lot of people go at that
narrative that kratos is getting soft
but to me it's like the the narrative
with joel
telling his name and stuff you know what
i'm saying like
after a certain amount of years and this
has been way more than joe ever could
have lived you know what i'm saying
you're actually just going to get more
soft
like especially you got to imagine like
the mindset of kratos he had a kid
he had a wife
like obviously you i mean i'm sure
there's a lot of people in the chat that
you know they you know they they don't
have a fake persona with a wife but
they're a lot more comfortable
showing a different side with their wife
you know what i'm saying like like
cradles
for years
had one goal one goal only i'mma kill
all the greek pathology gods and he he
achieved it
i want to know more about
why
he lived that's my thing but at the end
of the day like after having a kid
having a wife seeing her die
you're not gonna have that same mindset
and i i feel like you see the
conflicting things in him where that old
kratos wants to come out but he still
tries to yo i got a kid you know what
i'm saying like
he keeps trying to be in that middle
ground i see that conflicting thing
you know when god of war spoilers damn
2016. i think that's when this game came
out uh
no god award did not come out 2016. did
it that may take 2018.
when you fought the stranger
you saw that old cradles come back out
of him you know what i'm saying like
it's just like look after a certain
amount of time you're not going to be
the same person you was i'm sure
everyone in this chat 10 years ago use a
different person
indeed imagine that kind of thought
process on a bigger scale
years you know what i'm saying like
like you're going to be different man
and i i get it like i i understand
people want that that hardcore kratos
he's not there anymore and you see like
i said with a stranger
how quick
he went from the strangers punching him
to kratos just smacked him across the
map you know what i'm saying like like
it's just it's different man like he's a
different person and i actually like
that because it shows character
development if i wanted the same kratos
and 2
in the 2000s with one through three
going doing what cradles does best guess
what hustle i go play those star wars
yeah you know in the words of jay-z hey
you want my old stuff buy my old albums
not for that
but i thought it was important for me to
bring that up and you but you mentioned
character development
i'm
i'm actually excited to see this form of
kratos but i ain't going a lot of when
when the traders can get at him a little
bit
i i was like cool that mean because that
what that shows me because atreus is a
half god or maybe you have to correct me
on that one he's a demigod
yes well what it showed me was he ain't
low like i ain't gonna say annoying but
he's not that little dude like he he
really ready for that like he's ready
for whatever he wants to get capable of
like yeah and then you can see in the
trailer that craig was like yo i've been
there i've killed gods you don't want
that life like he's being a father like
like look like he's like one of those
old-time fathers that's like real real
real tough love kind of person you know
what i'm saying but when it comes down
to it that person's there you know what
i'm saying like
and that's what i enjoy
i'm re-watching it now oh god go ahead
quarter god half giant i don't know man
he's
so black ronan said he still seems
annoying i i think that's more about he
just wants to know who he is he wants to
know where he came from man
and i i love what i saw but now look
hustle did this game look it's too like
the 2018 version
i mean yes and no but i don't care like
the 2000 if if something looked good and
you don't have to spend as much time
making it necessarily better but you can
make other elements of the the visuals
you don't have to mess with the visuals
and you can make everything else better
then i'll never trip off that i'm cool
like this isn't that i think that when
people was overreacting to that they act
like this is like a far cry far cry game
or something dawg like yo this god of
war like yo you give sony santa monica
some more credit than that like that's
what i'm worried about and um
and i don't know if we're gonna get to
it i don't know if we're gonna have time
but uh
they saw a black black girl in there
y'all relax yes
relax
but i can't understand certain people
being upset with it but it's just like
at the same time like look like first
off this is this is a fiction game like
we can't go
like kratos isn't even supposed to be
here like
so we can change someone's race and it's
okay because we put a whole bean in this
place and he ain't supposed to be here
do you think kratos
and uh in north pathology going around
killing people tell me that chat do you
think he's going around killing people
he ain't going around killing gods
cradles ain't even
there
in fact
loki isn't even
a trace is loki but we all know how loki
is in the marvel universe but whatever
whatever forget all that who was the
super tall cat that they went to go get
did i have to beat the first one of war
apparently
gotcha that is
the north mythology of kratos and what's
funny is kratos is still half half a god
i'm pretty sure he's zeus is kid
i if i remember correctly i can't
remember everything about god of war so
like technically loki is part giant part
in part greek mythology god i don't know
norse mythology that way so i don't know
is loki like is
is the what's what i'm looking for is
the the ice giants in them are they part
gods like i don't know how that goes
someone in the chat correct me i don't
know
but to me what i saw was good what i saw
hype me up to have a playstation look i
get it it's on a ps4 i don't care i got
a ps5 i got this i don't got that other
one so that it's irrelevant what it's on
because i only got one system it's going
to be on
also um
side note i guess we got the name reveal
um people were calling that god when
ragnarok from jump anyway but um they
confirmed it
they confirmed this now um like i said
no release date but i'm not gonna lie
man like
i'll tell you like when people was
making those stupid little videos about
boat animations and all that i don't
care about that dog you get you get in
and out the same way from grand theft
auto um san andreas to um part three and
then vice city you get in and out of the
car the same way um inhaler i think it's
the same way who cares
so
relax if it's already good then you
don't really gotta worry about it they
go you you can fix everything else they
hopped in the belt the wrong way if
y'all don't cut it out and shout out the
friend cause fred oh yeah i saw the end
of the garden war she said she was gonna
be on kratos's ass boy she was you know
taylor she was on them
yo did she transform from a bird or
something or am i bugging because i
think that's i think she
that's that's wow and you know what the
whole thing started with like he was
trying to get the stranger because she
was about oh
can i spoil that
no never mind never never mind no i was
going to spoil the ending the god of war
but
kratos
was trying to do the right thing and now
he got more trouble but it's more
trouble than what it's worth
but whatever i'm looking forward to it
i don't care if they say they got some
type of sjw agenda about this one
writing that that one right there don't
forget we know y'all wouldn't do it but
don't harass none of the writers don't
harass none of the staff dog just let
the let this art
be this art that's it that's it in that
song man like there's no other way to
even like i'm looking at it now dawg
like the joint look crazy good like and
i love snow levels like i know a few
people who who i interact with they
don't like the snow stuff i like the
snow stuff
i just i've always been like a fan of
that i've always been a fan of like the
physics and all that type of stuff it
looks good
it looked like i don't think that you
first of all you got to end the show
with this
you definitely got to end the show with
this after
the after the order they had everything
in you had you had to finish like super
strong
that was that was something something to
behold man
i look forward to it um like i said we
got no year though but i think king he
jokingly said 2025 25.
yeah if this game came out in 2024 it
wouldn't surprise me and i probably i
won't even be mad at it i won't be mad
therefore
yeah so let's go ahead
give our overall perspective on the show
as far as what the industry was hyping
the show and as far as the content shown
to the content that was relevant to the
majority of people do you think this was
do you think the show delivered
yes i got a score okay i gave it eight
out of ten um my only my only complaint
i know third party had to be there but i
wish they would have put their titles
in a better position to be like but i
mentioned that earlier
playstation game it's some third-party
stuff playstation first part first title
game
hit andy stuff playstation first part
title game his whatever else and then we
finish with god of war
that that would have just been ideal to
me uh what and i guess you figured you
put wolverine in the middle for like the
surprise because nobody saw that camera
like none of none of us that that was
dope
that was dope but i i i wish they would
have did it that way but i'm not gonna
net pick that
good show to me i had a good time man i
definitely had a good time watching that
yeah and i feel like that's the thing we
need to notice the most like i do
personally feel like in terms of what
the industry hyped it didn't deliver but
i do feel like in terms of what i wanted
it delivered and i think you know i've
said multiple times i don't care what
other people i care what i want and uh
what i saw on there it definitely uh
made me want to you know i got a ps5 and
i don't need to get rid of it because
they showed me stuff i need for it uh i
you know for those of you that watched
iop a couple weeks ago
microsoft i feel like wouldn't have this
kind of show because they always giving
their best content to other shows
you know
and you know hopefully throughout the
next couple years that will change
uh but you know as far as this show i
think it was a solid show
i gave it an eight out of ten i'm
sticking with that i think it was uh you
know gave us exactly what we needed to
see
but
let's go ahead and end this up it was a
little bit longer than normal but we had
to talk about a lot about this man so
hustle where can the people find you at
you can find me on twitter youtube well
twitter and youtube hustle and motivate
um i will link one of those things in
the thing and oh thank y'all man like
this
a little bit nerve-wracking i can't lie
like i wasn't a little nervous in the
very beginning but
y'all got my back man and it's one of
those things like addict
again man like your cosine has always
meant a lot to me you've always gone out
of your way
i'll say this before i go bro er erica
tell you like we had a conversation i
was gonna stop i wasn't even gonna do
this
i wasn't i wasn't geeked up they even
like do this no more and not even 24
hours later i forget what episode of
iron laws it was you came out of no way
i was like hey y'all make sure y'all go
follow hustling motivating and so on and
so forth having like
the actual community behind me from
fosurelli the big cloud the game before
say he was in there cog and all the like
the converse from from you guys
community man it didn't mean the world
to me and it made me want to work harder
now man so
you know just and knowing that you
the team want me it wasn't just you was
like everybody was like yeah you bring
hustle in the fold a little bit to be a
part of the community nice to be a part
of everything that that you guys are
doing
yeah hey look man i'll do my best i'm
gonna do my best i promise you that i
promise you that the effort will be
there man
i'm excited
i'm excited man is yeah what's up what's
up like i said man you know you was
always uh
definitely top for the candidates uh in
seconds i wanted energy i wanted passion
and availability and it's hard to get
all of them you know someone might have
more energy but they don't have enough
passion someone might more passionate
about energy but they ain't never
available so you know yeah
when it comes to doing this you got to
find
someone that fits your chemistry and
we've always had good chemistry and you
got to find someone that's available
and you know
i i got i don't i don't want to work
with people
that i can't rely on and it's one thing
that you miss an episode or two you know
but it's just like you can't miss weekly
you know what i'm saying and i don't
think people realize the commitment
podcasting has
you know yeah i can't do anything
between five to seven because that's the
window uh we don't normally go to seven
but we can't do anything from that
tuesdays because i gotta host it i look
at from cognito's perspective cognino
can't do anything sunday because he's
hosting iop i could vote out early on
iop if i have something i have to do
cognito not so much especially the host
is a lot goes into this there's a lot of
prepping going in uh cognito spends so
much time prepping all the time shout
out to him those intros came straight
from cognito he's the one that developed
that style he's the one that went that
direction
a lot of goes into this podcasting stuff
and we wouldn't be anywhere but the
community itself we had about 170 in
here i appreciate everyone for coming
through man definitely go follow hustle
i'm going to most likely put uh
like a little section in the description
for the attic show
where uh we're gonna be uh so definitely
follow our social medias and you know
until next week this is gamey addict and
uh hustle